so this is an inequality um we don't
tend to see inequalities as the you know
when when we're trying to prove an
inequality um your brain often goes into
um
uh
like nature of proof mode right you're
like oh what kind of thing do i have to
do here now i've already kind of
immediately spoiled something by saying
hey this is in the topic of further
integration even though no integral
appears in here however i wonder if you
can post in the chat and tell me even
though no integral sign appears there's
no
obvious notation that indicates um
calculus right i wonder if you can post
in the chat and tell me there is
specific language nonetheless that
actually very very obviously clues into
you that when you think about your other
four topics you're like this has got to
be further integration what words or
what clues can you tell me
yeah okay fantastic you guys got it
pretty quick it says by comparing
relevant areas right and then they go
ahead and they give you y equals log x
so being that is something which we will
need to work out an area under a curve
and it's this weird awkward thing that
if you were just an advanced student you
could work out the area under a curve by
reverse engineering an area bounded to
the y axis and then subtracting it from
a rectangle that's a classic um harder
version of an advanced question that a
student who is in advance could still
solve however as extension two students
you guys can go like straight forward
you can integrate that um y equals log x
curve using well do you want to go and
ahead and tell me what's the extra
knowledge that you have as extension to
students that lets you integrate y
equals log x you post in the chat let me
know
yeah fantastic assessments on fire today
that's like two from two that you've
been first not that being first is the
only thing that matters but but
definitely well done okay and thank you
veren as well so um i'm gonna give you
because some people only just arrived
i'm to give you another two to three
minutes on this question i really hope
there's a bunch of you who said like yep
i'm done i've got it because i arrived a
bit early good for you if that is you by
the way um and you haven't already
please download the 2013 hsc paper the
link is directly on canvas and just go
over to part c it's another integration
question that we're going to get to in
the second half of this lesson so don't
don't wait around
but for the rest of you
i'll go back on mute and give you a bit
more time
to finish out this inequality proof okay
good luck come back in about two three
minutes um in that case i think we're
ready to go let's have a look at this
and uh let's see how similar or
different your solution is by the way
this question as often is the case it
does say or otherwise so i'd be
interested to know if you can find out
some other equally elegant way to do
this
i did mention like there's an advanced
way to do this but i i would hesitate to
um to draw on it because i think it
would be more work than it's worth
especially because we know how to handle
integration by parts
so let's begin have a think about what
the question tells us
you're trying to find out uh how we can
prove this inequality down here is true
right and then they sort of specify
because t is greater than one um domain
restriction on when this inequality is
true now the reason why is because t you
wanted to be able to move anywhere
around here giving you this kind of
shape in here that we can see on the
diagram but you don't want it to move
past over here because then you're like
what's going on there you've got some
kind of different diagram over here
where different kind of properties might
apply so the relevant areas that this
question sort of specifies for us you
might have already worked it out are
going to be this triangle that they've
just kind of inexplicitly
illustrated for us and then the area
under the curve and it's the area under
the curve where our integration by past
knowledge is going to help us
so to set this out i think the most easy
way to start it is to say well look at
the inequality which side is bigger and
the answer is it's the left-hand side so
on the left hand side is where i'm going
to place the larger area now when you
relate these two the area under the
curve log x and then the triangle pretty
obvious which one is larger the triangle
is always beneath the curve so i'm going
to say the area
under the curve
is going to be always greater than the
area of the triangle
and this kind of charts our path through
okay now
the area under the curve we can just
simply state that as starting from that
lower boundary of one and then it's
going all the way up until t so that
gives us this definite integral from one
to t
and then the actual curve is just log x
right so we'll deal with that shortly as
i've already said a few times
integration by paths but before we can
move on to that we need to know what the
other area the other relevant area is so
the triangle it takes just a teeny bit
of effort right
so i would say that the easiest part to
work out is the base first so if you
have a look at the base of this
horizontally here um it's going to be
this t length gives you the entire thing
all the way to the y axis but then
you've got one unit here which isn't
included so therefore we would say this
t minus 1. and that also indicates like
if you didn't put that t is greater than
one domain restriction
then you'd have a negative base length
right so you don't want that so there's
going to be our base and then if you
have a look vertically this is going to
be our height here and it just takes the
briefest moment to have to think about
well how would you determine the height
of this triangle it's going to come from
the y coordinate of this point that
gives you that right hand edge and you
can see that's going to be t comma log t
because of the curve that it sits on y
equals log x so therefore that gives me
that height there like i said it's the y
coordinate so we're pretty much ready to
go right i'm going to go half uh where's
my colors here here's base
and then here comes the height log
t and at this point because i've made
the um that t minus one there this is
where i'm going to say well therefore t
has to be greater than one
all right
we're ready to go that right hand side
is not not much is going to happen to it
for a little while but you can see it's
kind of promising it's got that t minus
one that you can see in the result we're
trying to prove that half is obviously
not there by accident it sort of relates
a little bit to the two that you can see
in the inequality that we need to get to
so let's deal with this integration by
parts first okay been a little while
perhaps for some of you since you've
done this so let's just review um you
would normally state this as the
integral of udv and you have to you know
select your u and select your dv
appropriately and you would write this
as uv minus the integral of v
d u except don't forget in this case
we're handling a definite integral with
integral parts uh integration by parts
so really if you're going from some
boundary a to b then this is going to be
evaluated this primitive function here
from a to b and then this secondary
integral here is also from a to b so
we've got our boundaries across the
board
all right now as usual we need to select
a u and a dv and have a think about this
maybe you've seen this one enough times
you're like i just don't even need to go
through the hierarchy the detail listing
um d-e-t-a-i-l
hopefully this one is obvious enough
that there's kind of like you can view
it as having a one hiding there and if
you choose that one as dv it's going to
make things cancel really nicely for us
right so let's just write that out i
tend to write the u equals log x and
then differentiate and have all my
derivatives on the right hand side you
guys have seen me do that before
so that's just going to be 1 over x
and you can see why a little bit more
space over here you can see why choosing
1 as my dv is going to be helpful
because we'll cancel things for me right
if i choose 1 there and go over to its
primitive then v is just going to be x
i'm not worrying about the constant
integration here because it's going to
be a definite integral anyway so you can
see that i'm going to get these two
things here canceling with each other in
my vdu shortly
okay so i'm just going to let's just
chuck a box around that
there we go
just so you can follow my own working
here so now let's do our integral right
i've got my
uv and i'm evaluating that from my lower
bound to my upper bound which in this
case my uv is x log x
and don't forget our particular
boundaries here are 1 and t and then
i'll subtract and here comes the vdu
right so i'm going to get x times 1 on x
dx by the way i think it is pretty
important
um that even though i think it's fairly
transparent what that's going to
simplify to this is a show result right
so you use the integration by part it's
not that difficult to write that that
extra step there to indicate i know what
i'm doing this vdu doesn't just come out
of nowhere
and then i can go ahead and integrate
okay
like i said this is not really going to
nothing's going to happen much to this
until i can deal with all those
integrals on the left hand side
all right what are we going to get here
well um upper bounds to evaluate so i'm
going to get t log t
and again even though i know what it's
going to be i want to be careful here
because it's a proved question so i'm
going to be having the lower boundary
there if one log one even though i know
that's about to pan out and become zero
this has become one inside that's the
integrand so when you integrate that up
you just get x and that's going to go
from one to t
let's be excessively lazy and just grab
all of this
there we go
um okay so as we said this term here is
going to cancel out to zero
and now i can sort of i think probably
it's going to be helpful for me to start
expanding pretty soon i'm going to have
a t log t over here and then this is
going to have a minus just be careful
with your signs here minus of t minus 1
so there's going to be double negatives
and i'm going to multiply all of that by
this half by this 2 rather that i can
see over on the right hand side i don't
know why i started to write that again
because i can just pull the same trick
okay so
on this next line i'm going to do two
things at the same time i'm going to
deal with this um expanding brackets
multiply through by two as well
and then i'll take it back i'm going to
do three things three things i think i
can expand the right hand side as well
because i'm going to have like terms
very very shortly so i'm going to get 2
2t
log t over here this is going to become
minus 2t this is a double negative so
it's going to become plus 2. here on the
right hand side that half i multiply it
through by 2 it's gone but when i expand
these brackets here you're going to see
that you get this t log t
that'll cancel or not cancel collect
with the left hand side and then a minus
log t over there so i hope you're
following along that this term here and
this term here are going to give us our
like terms
all right what do we have here well i
think from this point you can see i'm
sort of within striking distance of this
result i'm trying to prove right so i'm
no longer just kind of simplifying a
little bit aimlessly i'm now trying to
pinpoint myself towards this particular
result they want there's a log t over
there by itself on the left hand side so
let's think about how to make that the
subject of this inequality i'm going to
get all my log terms on the left and i'm
going to get everything else on the
right so let's see here
i'll just get left with one oopsy daisy
don't highlight that
one t log t on the right hand side once
you subtract i'll add log t to both
sides
and then i will
add everything from this part here on
the left hand side so it ends up on the
right
you can see that t minus 1 once we
factor that out so i will factor out on
the left hand side first there we go and
then i'll factor on the right hand side
second
and that was a horrendously messy
inequality sign so let's fix that and
we're pretty much home aren't we from
here i can just divide through
and it is important to mention as well
you get the two there and you've got
this t minus one on t plus one but as a
very minor point of nitpicking i think
you have to be careful at this point
because this is a show result right and
i just divided through by an algebraic
expression t plus one
t is variable right so
when we divide through by something you
have to be cautious about whether it
mucks with the direction of your
inequality these are not equations that
we're dealing with here right so can you
tell me why i can do this and not just
sort of walk off and um you know
drop the mic right there's something i
need to say i said right earlier on but
i need to invoke it now because just i
did the division right what am i going
to have to say to conclude here
you want to go ahead and post
yeah thank you very much you can see
right back up here we said t is greater
than one so i'm going to say the way i'm
going to invert that i can say since
t plus one because that's the actual
thing that i divided through by is
greater than
well t is greater than one so t plus one
is greater than two but all i really
need to know is it's actually greater
than zero right and that's what gives me
the fact that i can divide through by it
and not change the direction of the
inequality so i can say that as required
full stop and finished
so i hope that made sense to you you can
see how i've set that working out it
isn't too dramatic if you know how to
handle that integration by pass i think
that's probably the single hardest thing
then you just have to be quite delicate
and thorough with your algebra